Fire Emblem three houses puts you in the
shoes of a new professor at the Gehrig
mock monastery after you choose a house
you need to motivate instruct and
befriend your students in order to
prepare them for the coming battles but
there's only so much time in a day and
to make the most of the school year and
beyond you have to use your time wisely
here's what you need to know to maximize
your time at Gehrig mach3 houses is
broken up into month-long chapters with
a story battle at the end of each unlike
persona you aren't living every single
school day alongside your students
instead you mostly have to deal with
Sunday's which are free days and
Monday's which are instruction days the
first month or so is a tutorial that
introduces you to this overall structure
and things like activity points your
professor level and your students
motivation and you will need to know
what those things are to understand this
video after that you're left to your own
devices and careful time management on
Sundays is key to making your weekend
month go well on a typical Sunday you
have four options for how to spend your
free time explore seminar battle and
rest your goal is to end each Sunday
with at least some of your students
motivated enough to learn on Monday
since the number of activity points you
have dictates how many students you can
teach you ideally want to have that
number of students at max motivation
before Monday comes around exploring the
monastery is the best and most reliable
way to motivate your students every time
you explore it you should share at least
one meal with them as long as they like
the food it'll max out their motivation
and give you some points towards your
professor level which is how you unlock
more activity points to spend it's super
important early on to prioritize
activities that raise your professor
level in addition to sharing a meal
tournaments are great for this if your
student wins you get money a nice prize
and a good amount of professor points
you have to balance that with making
sure your students are motivated though
the least productive use of an activity
point is choir practice since its
experience rewards are minimal and it
doesn't increase motivation the good
news is you don't always need activity
points to motivate your students giving
them gifts will refill their motivation
gauges at no activity cost a basic gift
will refill a quarter of the gauge and a
gift they really like will get you
halfway there returning a lost item will
also refill half so I recommend waiting
until your students are burnt out before
returning an item
you think is theirs you can get a sense
of your students likes and dislikes by
looking at the roster in their notes
section giving gifts doesn't raise your
professor level but I have more good
news
fishing and gardening don't cost any
activity points and both will net use
some professor points each fish you reel
in grants a handful of points and is
good for levelling up quickly in the
beginning while a good haul in the
garden will get you more points plant
related seeds so veggies with veggies
flowers with flowers to increase
productivity plus if you plant flower
seeds you'll also get flowers that can
be use as gifts ash likes violets and
flame likes forget-me-nots by the way
that about covers exploring but there
are three other options on Sundays and
none of them are as good at keeping your
students motivation up battles are the
least reliable the MVP can get their
motivation maxed out but only for
certain important battles that said
battling is incredibly important for
leveling your units up and getting
rewards like money I usually save my
battles for the last Sunday of the month
when there's no instruction the
following Monday on Normal difficulty
you can grind out the battles that don't
take an activity point to get the most
out of a battle day that leaves seminars
and resting seminars are great for
improving your students skills as well
as your own and they refill half the
motivation gauge for those who attend
wresting has the benefit of repairing
that powerful sword you get early on but
it only refills a quarter of the
motivation gauge neither option is going
to get students to full motivation in
one go which limits the number of times
you can instruct them on Mondays
this is where recruiting comes in I
highly recommend recruiting students
from other houses for a number of
reasons but as far as time management
goes it helps to have an A team and a B
team for your monday instruction time if
your class size is at least double your
activity points you can spend a Sunday
say battling and still have a pool of
people to teach on the following Monday
I was hesitant to recruit people during
my first playthrough but it really only
has benefits so try to recruit the
characters you're interested in as soon
as possible no spoilers but if you're
not in the Black Eagles I'd recommend
going for dorotheya who is the perfect
candidate for a dance situation later in
the school year the school year is after
all just one year so it's important to
make the most of it before the real
battles arrive time management is hard
but hopefully these tips help make the
school calendar a little less stressful
and if you have any other time
maximizing ideas please
no in the comments for our next
playthrough
[Music]